you've uh written a book about
how the role and power of the presidency
has changed
so has how has it changed
since lincoln's time the evolution of
the presidency
as a concept which seems like a
fascinating lens through which
to look at american history as a
president
you know we seem to only be talking
about the presidents
maybe a general here and there but it's
mostly the the story of america is often
told
through presidents that's right that's
right
and one of the points i've tried to make
in my writing about this
and and various other activities is we
use this word president as if it's
something timeless
but the office has changed incredibly
just
in link from lincoln's time to the
present which is you know 150 years
he wouldn't recognize the office uh
today and george washington would not
have recognized it in lincoln
just as i think a ceo today would be
unrecognizable
to a rockefeller or a carnegie of 150
years ago
so what are some of the ways in which
the office has changed i'll just point
to three there are
a lot one presidents now can communicate
with the public directly i mean we've
reached the point now where a president
can have direct almost one-on-one
communication president can use twitter
if he so chooses to circumvent
all media that was unthinkable lincoln
in order to get his message across often
wrote letters to newspapers
and waited for the newspaper for horus
greeley in the new york tribune to
publish uh his life that's how he
communicated with the public there
weren't even many
speaking opportunities so that's a big
change right we feel the president in
our
life much more that's why we talk about
him much more
uh that also creates more of a burden
that's the second point presidents are
under a microscope
presidents are under a microscope you
have to be very careful what you do and
what you say and you're judged by a lot
of the
elements of your behavior that are not
policy relevant in fact the things we
judge most and make most of our
decisions on about individuals are often
that and then
third the power the president has
um it's inhuman actually and this is one
of my critiques of how the office has
changed this one person
uh has power on a scale that's that's i
think dangerous in a democracy
and certainly uh something the founders
years ago would have had trouble
conceiving um presidents now have the
ability to deliver force across the
world to
to literally assassinate people with a
remarkable accuracy
uh and that's an enormous power that
presidents have so your sense
this is not to get conspiratorial but do
you think
a president currently has the power to
you know initiate the assassination of
somebody
of a political um enemy
or like a terrorist leader or that kind
of thing to
to frame that person in a way where
assassination is something that he alone
or she alone could decide to do i think
it happens all the time and it's not to
be conspiratorial this is how we've
fought terrorism
by uh targeting individuals now you
might say these were not elected leaders
of state but these were individuals with
a large following i mean the killing of
osama bin laden
was was an assassination operation um
and we've we've taken out very
successfully
many leaders of terrorist organizations
and and we do it every day
you're saying that back in lincoln's
time or george washington's time there
was more of a balance of power like
a president could not initiate this kind
of assassination correct i think
presidents did not have the same kind of
military
or economic power we could talk about
how a president can influence a market
right by saying something about
where money is going to go or uh
singling out a company or critiquing a
company in one way or another
they didn't have that kind of power now
much of the prep power that a lincoln or
a washington had was the power to
mobilize people to then make their own
decisions
at the start of the civil war lincoln
doesn't even have the power to bring
people into the army he has to go to the
governors
and ask the governors to provide
soldiers so the governor of wisconsin
the governor of massachusetts could you
imagine that today
so but yeah so they use speeches and
words to mobilize
versus direct action in closed-door
environments
initiating wars for example correct
you